- They value safety and Dave,
the illusion of safety
more than they value
personal liberty.
And that's why they
went along with it.
I have very, very many
intelligent friends
who just couldn't wait
to put that mask on.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is a former New Jersey
superior court judge
and host of the "Judging
Freedom" podcast,
Judge Andrew Napolitano.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
- A pleasure to be
on with you, Dave,
thank you for having me.
- I'm glad to have you.
Before we dive into
the issues of the day,
and there's a lot of stuff sort
of culturally, politically,
but especially legally that
I want to talk to you about.
There's a rumor
that you might be up
on a farm somewhere in
the middle of nowhere.
And I find that
to be interesting
considering most people
picture you with a suit,
slicked back hair, some makeup,
but you like living
on a farm, huh?
- Well, for 24 years, I
was very happy at Fox News.
They put me in
front of a camera.
You ready for this?
14,500 times.
And they have the
clothes police there,
really wonderful people,
but made sure you
were dressed properly.
And the makeup was right
and your hair was right.
Since COVID and then
after I left Fox,
I've been doing
everything from my farm,
which is where I am now,
which is at the northwest
tip of New Jersey,
where New York, New Jersey,
and Pennsylvania meet.
We average about 15 degrees
colder than New York City.
So I've left here in a
blizzard and got to Manhattan
and it's just rain.
We're we're about 1,800
feet above sea level.
- And what are you
doing up on a farm?
I mean, are you out there?
Are you pulling up vegetables
and you got some
animals out there,
what are you doing?
- I sign the checks,
the wonderful guys that work
for me get dirty fingernails.
We just finished
making maple syrup.
We grow, we have an apple
orchard and a pear orchard,
and we grow about
500 pounds of garlic.
And we grow a lot
of green vegetables.
Our clients are hotels and
restaurants in the area.
It's a lot of fun.
It's given me an appreciation
for the environment
that I never had before
I had this property.
- Yeah, very cool.
I just thought it was
worth mentioning up top
because I think when
people see people,
especially on cable news,
there's something about
seeing the person in the box
where you don't realize that
they're actually a person too,
that they just appear
to be this head floating
with a fancy background.
- Well like you, I am
very much a person.
- You are very much a person.
All right, well, let's do
a little bit of the person.
So former superior
court judge in Jersey,
what got you interested in
the law in the first place?
How does someone
end up as a judge?
People think of law,
you become a lawyer.
How did you end up as a
judge in the first place?
- Well I ended up as a lawyer
because at dinner
table conversations,
I always took the
side of the underdog,
much to my parents' dismay.
I loved debating in high
school and even in college.
So I went to Princeton and one
of my classmates, Sam Alito,
one of my boyhood friends is now
on the Supreme Court
of the United States.
New Jersey's system is a little
different than other states.
You practice law for 10 years.
And then after that are
eligible to be appointed.
I was the youngest
person appointed
in the history of the state.
I was actually appointed
before I had completed
that 10 year mark,
but I didn't take office
until after I completed.
Appointed by the governor,
confirmed by the state
senate for seven years,
if reappointed and reconfirmed
before the end of seven,
you have it for life.
So I was appointed by a
wonderful moderate Republican,
Governor Tom Kane,
and then seven years later
received my lifetime appointment
by another wonderful
moderate Republican,
Governor Christine Todd Whitman.
At the trial level where I was,
where there are 400
judges in the state,
there are roughly 200
Republicans and 200 Democrats.
So it's not political
because it's not a
policy making court.
You're trying cases, you're
deciding who you believe.
You're not making decisions
like the Supreme Court of
the United States does.
- How did you make
sure that your politics
didn't leak into it?
I mean I have a sense
from watching you
over the years of what
your politics are,
but I know you try to
be, as on your show,
you try to be as
nonpartisan as possible,
but obviously people
have their own biases,
have their own ways of
looking at the world.
How did you do it?
And do you think that enough
judges are doing it these days?
Because it does seem these days,
that courts seem to be slanted
one one way or another.
- Well, I, like you, believe
that our rights are natural
and come from our humanity,
whether you believe
in God as I do
and that it's a gift from God,
or whether you believe we
have developed these rights
by our own exercise of reason,
they don't come
from the government.
They're not privileges,
they're not licenses,
they're rights, they're claims.
And therefore I believe
that the constitution
literally means what it says.
If the government wants to take
life, liberty, or property,
it has to follow due process,
which means a jury trial
at which the government
proves fault,
it doesn't mean an edict
thou shalt wear a mask.
Thou shalt take a vaccine.
Thou shalt not stand
closer than six feet
from the next person.
Thou shalt not open your
restaurant business.
All of those in my view are
unconstitutional, unlawful,
and immoral because they
violate your natural rights.
Does that seep into
the judicial process?
Yes, it does.
Before a criminal trial,
the government must
demonstrate to the court
how it acquired the
evidence in the case,
because the Supreme Court
of the United States
and the Supreme Court of
New Jersey have both rule.
If the evidence was
obtained unlawfully,
then it's that the
police broke of the law,
when they're ostensibly
enforcing the law,
then the evidence can't
be introduced at trial.
If you are a natural
law libertarian as I am,
you tend to follow that to a T.
Translated,
I probably suppressed more
evidence than all the other
judges in the
courthouse combined.
So I was not the
prosecutor's favorite
except on sentencings,
then they loved me because
there's a wing of the New Jersey
state prison with my name on
it because I sent so many bad,
violent people there,
not people who committed
harmless crimes,
but people who
committed real crimes.
So yes, it's more a
philosophy than a politics
that filters into
the judging process.
- [Dave] Do you remember-
- Having said that, much
of it is mechanical.
You're trying a case.
You wanna make sure
the jury understands.
You wanna make sure both
sides get a fair shake.
Even in sentencing,
talking about Jussie Smollett
three or four times this week.
Had an unusual
twist the other day,
when the appellate court
let him out for the reason
for which they let him out.
But when judges sentence, Dave,
they have a checklist,
25 aggravating factors,
25 mitigating factors.
So you're not shooting
from your hip.
You're deciding do the
aggravating factors
outweigh the mitigating factors.
Is this a human being
who really is a danger
to society and needs
to be locked up?
Or is this somebody who
just got carried away,
got involved in something
and it got outta control
and he didn't have the courage
to admit that it was wrong.
You have to make those objective
and subjective judgements
before you take
someone's freedom away.
- So I wanna get more
Smollett in just a minute,
but I find that really
interesting about,
so you really tried to
keep the law of the letter
regarding policing and if
they broke the law, okay,
the evidence can't be submitted.
Were there times,
I'm sure there were,
that you saw something
that was so damning,
so incriminating, and
you're going, man,
if I don't let
this be submitted,
there's a really bad
dude who's about to walk
and yet you'd still
have to do it.
- Yes, yes you do.
And I talked to
police about this.
Police who have beaten
confessions out of people
or cracked a taillight
after they stop the car
because they got a tip that
drugs were in the trunk
and they needed a lawful basis
for smashing the taillight.
I said to one of
them, I said, you know
you and I grew up in
the same neighborhood.
I didn't come down
with yesterday's rain.
You know I was gonna
see through this.
And he said, yes, here's
how we look at it.
We got this stuff
off the street.
We know a guilty guy went free
and he's probably
gonna do it again.
And we'll get him the next time.
And the next time
we'll follow the law,
but we just took 10 pounds
of cocaine off the street.
Our problem was that
we got assigned to you
because you're the only
judge in the courthouse
that would have caught
us for doing this.
So there are factors to weigh,
but my oath is to
the constitution when
I was on the bench.
It's not to the government,
it's not to the prosecutors,
it's not to the police,
it's to the constitution.
It's the constitution
that mandates
that illegally obtained
evidence can't be used
in a trial in America.
If it could, there
would be no trials.
Everybody would plead
guilty because the police
would beat the crap
out of everybody.
- So I wanna get to
the issues of the day
and we'll talk about Smollett
and the Supreme Court
justice nominee
and all that stuff.
But so what possessed
you to go from the court,
which you obviously loved.
It's very obvious
hearing you talk about it
to saying hey I'll do
this on television,
which is a whole other game.
- Well I'm a little
embarrassed to tell you
except it's public knowledge
because I said it at the time,
I was tired of being poor.
So judges at the time made a
hundred thousand dollars a year
with zero outside income.
In addition to being a judge,
I was a full-time law professor,
but teaching just at night
so it didn't interfere
with my judicial duties.
I was also lecturing
around the country
about the types of things
that we're talking about,
human liberty and
natural rights.
And one day one of my
clerks, a very bright person
said to me do you know
if you could charge
the fair market value for
this stuff you do at night,
it would be two and a half times
what the state is paying you
for what you do during the day.
Eh, that was it.
I didn't leave the bench
to go on television.
I left the bench to go back
into the pits and try cases.
Eight or nine years before,
I had met Roger Ailes
at the Kansas City
Republican National
Convention in 1976,
Ronald Reagan
versus Gerald Ford.
Roger was the chief strategist
for one of the two camps.
I'll let you guess
which camp it was.
Almost everybody says Reagan,
he was on Ford's side.
- No well that's why I paused
because I thought you were
setting me up for a trap there.
- Right.
Well Ford was the President
of the United States.
Anyway, that's where
I met Roger Ailes.
I left the bench.
The statement about
being poor had such legs,
it was all over the place.
Life tenured judge
leaves because of,
a poor salary and you can't
earn an outside income
and people dumped on me.
What do you mean a hundred
thousand dollars is poor.
That's more than 90%
of the country makes
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Roger Ailes read about it.
OJ Simpson had
just been indicted.
Ailes was then the
president of CNBC.
He said we're gonna cover this.
And I'm gonna put my
own ex-judge on air
to second guess this
crazy loopy Judge Ito.
So for five days a week
with my future colleague at
Fox, John Gibson, we covered OJ.
John in the courtroom
and interviewing people
outside the courthouse
and me providing analysis
for CNBC at their offices in
Englewood Cliffs, New Jersey.
Then Microsoft and
NBC formed MSNBC.
Roger did not get
the presidency of it,
probably the worst
mistake NBC ever made.
He left, formed Fox,
and brought those of us
who had worked for him
at CNBC over to Fox
basically said I don't
know where it's gonna go.
It's a gamble.
We could all be
bankrupt in a week.
Now that was 25, 26 years ago.
- And did you feel
covering from OJ
to all the stuff that you
cover, were covering on Fox
for 15, 20 years, actually more.
Did you feel that
there is a risk
in doing some of that day to day
on cable news that you
have to be more sensational
or that you maybe aren't
privy to all the information
that's going on
in the courtroom.
Or you gotta keep people
watching and know,
you know one of the
things that I find tough
when you follow court
cases these days,
the way everyone seems
to do on cable news,
we're suddenly privy to
all of this information
that maybe we all shouldn't
be privy to all the time,
or at least the public
shouldn't care about
every little in and out
of every little thing.
How do you try to blend that?
- I agree with you
that the public
shouldn't care about
every little in and out
and every little thing,
but in this era of
cable news, we do.
I don't know how the founding
fathers would've fared
if cable news had been
around at the time.
- Not well, not well.
- Fox had and has
terrific researchers.
They also allowed me
to hire my own
researcher, a lawyer.
In between Fox's researchers,
known affectionately
as the brain room
and my researcher,
I was able to devour
what I needed to know.
Occasionally you make a mistake,
sometimes a mistake
leads to a lawsuit.
But remember you are explaining
things for the public,
you're not making an argument
before the Supreme Court.
So you don't need
to know everything.
The key is to explain it so
that the public understands it,
appreciates the explanation,
and wants more of it.
- Okay so with that in mind,
let's switch to some of
the issues of the day.
So you brought up the
Jussie Smollett thing,
which we covered a whole
bunch over the last few weeks.
So he gets sentenced,
there's really no one
other than him I suppose
and his lawyer who's claiming
that he's still innocent.
I mean it's sort of bananas.
And everyone saw the
diatribe at the end
during the sentencing.
He gets the 150 days in jail
and a couple other things,
but basically he's gonna
serve a week in jail
and that's it, they're
gonna let him out.
What do you make
of the sentencing,
then the shortening
and just the media part of this.
And how do you think
the judge had to deal
with the media portion of it?
- Okay the media is
not easy to deal with.
In the era that I was
on the bench, Dave,
cameras were not
permitted in courtrooms
and in the few courtrooms in
which they were permitted,
the judge had an absolute
right to exclude them.
Today you can't exclude them.
In federal court
they're not permitted,
but in state courts,
they're there all the time.
They're tiny.
They don't make any
noise after a while.
You forget that they're
there, but they are there,
which is what we all know more
detail than we need to know.
I thought his
sentencing was fair.
Normally, lying to the police
does not implicate jail time.
I have a problem with
punishing people for lying
to the police or
lying to the FBI
because the law allows the FBI
and the police to lie to you.
So if they can lie-
Do you remember the
Martha Stewart case?
They lied to her in
the same conversation
in which she lied to them.
The FBI agent who lied
to her got a promotion.
She went to jail for six
months for lying to them.
So I have a problem with that.
- Quick sidebar on that,
I was a PA on Martha
Stewart's talk show
when she came back
after jail time,
and she still had the
monitor on her foot
when she was doing the show.
- When she came to Fox,
she asked for me and
hugged and kissed me.
We are from two towns
next to each other,
Bloomfield, New Jersey
and Nutley, New Jersey.
Bloomfield very
Italian at the time,
Nutley very Polish.
- I know Bloomfield well.
- Her name is no more
Stewart than mine is Smith,
but she promoted
that very, very well.
- Got it.
- Now back to Jussie.
Because the lies were regular,
consistent, systematic,
and because the government
wasted 125 to $150,000
investigating the lies,
I believe that the jail
sentence of 150 days
and the restitution to the
government was appropriate.
Now his sentence
was not shortened.
He was let off on appeal.
It's an interesting reason
why it was let off on appeal
because if he started
serving 150 days immediately,
he would be finished
with it before the appeal
would ever even be heard.
Because it takes a year or
two for the appellate courts
to hear your appeal because
the appeals get online
on the basis of when
they were filed.
So he's still facing
150 days in jail
unless the appellate
court decides either that
he was wrongfully convicted
or that he was over punished.
I don't think
either is the case.
- Right.
In a situation like that,
so when they finally get to it,
do they usually just say, ah,
we're sort of past this thing
and just let him
go at this point?
- Well no,
because the prosecutors
will be pounding the table.
The appellate court
would have to find
that the trial was unfair,
that the trial judge made
mistakes of such a magnitude,
that he was not proven guilty
or that the sentence was unfair.
The sentence was not unfair,
it was well within the range
that the statute allows.
So his only hope is to find
that because the
first prosecutor said
I'm not gonna prosecute you,
they shouldn't have assigned
it to a second prosecutor.
That's his only hope on appeal
that once a prosecutor said,
we're not prosecuting you,
that that was it.
Most states once
a prosecutor says
we're not gonna prosecute you,
they don't send it to
another prosecutor.
They did it because Jussie
became very, very unpopular
in the Chicago community.
Now you shouldn't be prosecuted
just because you're unpopular.
You should be prosecuted
if there's enough evidence
to convict and if your
behavior has caused harm.
- Where does that, that.
If your behavior
has caused harm,
where does that go when it
comes to the prosecuting?
Meaning that in terms of the
actual crime he committed
to set up this hoax,
there's not a lot
of damage done,
but I think you could argue
that there was a tremendous
amount of damage
done to society,
to the city of Chicago,
but the whole country in
terms of this culture war
that we're fighting,
how often do you think
judges are affected by that?
That there's a much
bigger fight at play
than the specifics of, oh, okay.
He paid these two guys.
He made up this thing, that
we could kind of look past,
but it's really that
you could argue that
then there were more
riots because of this,
or just the general
flame of the culture war
continues because of
something like this.
- So that cannot be
taken into account
at the time of sentencing.
But here's something that can be
that I think will interest you
and the folks
listening to us now.
When I told you
there's a checklist,
25 aggravating and 25
mitigating factors.
One of the aggravating factors
is the defendant committed
this crime as a cost
of doing business.
Now that was put in there
because of mafia guys
who committed crimes as
a cost of doing business.
And the judge in my
opinion, quite properly,
did check that box.
Jussie concocted
this whole thing
as a cost of doing business.
Now, he and I ultimately
had the same bosses
because we both worked for Fox.
I mean he's crazy to think
that he's gonna get a leg up
at Fox by concocting
this nonsense,
maybe at another network,
but not at Fox.
They'd be sorry
that it happened,
but that's not going to,
not gonna help the careers.
But back to your question,
the only harm was
to the government.
The only harm traceable to
his behavior was $150,000
in police overtime
investigating an event
that never occurred.
Now he was with six lies
because they interrogated
him six times and
each time he gave them
the same nonsensical story.
He was convicted of five.
We won't know why without
asking the jurors,
the sixth one did not
result in a conviction.
Each of those could have
been three years in jail
and he ended up with 150 days.
- All right so let's shift to
a couple of the other things
going on right now.
So obviously Joe
Biden has selected
Ketanji Brown Jackson
to be his nominee
for the Supreme Court.
I have no doubt that this
once the hearings begin
will be as chaotic as ever,
maybe not quite as chaotic
as Brett Kavanaugh,
'cause she's kind of on
the side of the media,
but the usual stuff
is gonna happen.
- Yep.
- I guess A, what would your
general qualifications be?
I think I have a
sense of that already.
And B, how do we pilfer
some truth out of this,
knowing that the media
is not gonna cover it
the way it would if say she
was nominated by Donald Trump
or a Republican president.
- I start with the premise
that under the constitution,
the president gets to
nominate whoever he wants
and believe it or not, Dave,
neither the constitution
nor a federal law
require that a Supreme Court
Justice even be a lawyer,
much less held prior
judicial experience.
The last justice who didn't
even graduate from law school
was Justice Robert Jackson,
who had been the attorney
general of the United States
under FDR.
And he is one of the
most quotable justices
in the modern era,
never graduated from law school.
Today of course the Senate
would not confirm anyone
who didn't graduate
from law school.
The Senate and the
presidents seem to prefer
people who have
judicial experience.
That's not required at all.
Chief Justice Earl Warren
had no judicial experience
and probably affected
jurisprudence in this country
more than anybody.
Chief Justice John Marshall,
the great chief justice
from the Thomas Jefferson
to the Andrew Jackson years.
He had no judicial experience.
And because Joe
Biden nominated her,
she's a liberal Democrat
that's to be expected.
Donald Trump, I'm very familiar
with his nomination processes.
I was intimately involved
the first time around.
Donald Trump, in my opinion,
nominated two conservatives
and one libertarian.
Libertarian is Neil Gorsuch.
The conservatives
are Amy Coney Barrett
who is a graduate of the
same law school as I am,
University of Notre Dame.
And Brett Kavanaugh.
That's the president's
prerogative.
I don't agree with Senator
Lindsey Graham and many things,
but I agree with him on this.
The president
nominated the person
and he or she is
basically qualified.
I'm going to vote for them.
I think that's what
the outcome will be
with Judge Ketanji
Brown Jackson.
However, there are
conservative Republicans
on the judiciary committee
and I know them both.
Well Ted Cruz have been a
friend of mine for years.
Josh Hawley, we have met
through the monitor like you
and I are meeting now.
They're going to
go for her jugular.
They're going to find
decisions that she made,
which she believes she was
compelled to make under the law,
which appear inexplicable
to the public.
Not to hurt her, not
to deny her the job,
because she'll certainly get it.
But to embarrass the president.
This started with Robert Bork.
- It was Joe Biden
who started it.
- High gear with
Clarence Thomas.
And then of course,
Brett Kavanaugh,
it doesn't happen
to all of them.
It didn't happen to
Amy Coney Barrett.
It did not happen to
Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
It did not happen
to Neil Gorsuch,
but every once in a while,
there is a nominee that
the minority party,
that's the party that's
not in the White House,
thinks they can tarnish the
person who did the nomination
by tarnishing the candidate.
History has shown that
does not carry over
into the nominees'
judicial opinions,
whatever you think
of Clarence Thomas,
he has either
forgiven or forgotten.
And the same thing
with Brett Kavanaugh.
Robert Bork of course
the trashing worked.
He was rejected by a vote of
52 against and 48 in favor.
- Yeah which Joe Biden
basically led the charge on.
- Yes he did.
- Do you think that
there's some value
in say Ted Cruz, Josh Hawley,
some of these other guys
going for the jugular,
even if she's gonna be
confirmed either way
just to at least expose
some of the thinking
behind the decisions
so that people can frame
the issues properly,
even if they can't stop it.
Even though, and of course,
it all becomes a
circus either way.
- I think the value is
to the political base.
- Yeah.
- Most respectfully
to my friends,
for Ted Cruz and Josh Hawley.
I don't think there's
any value to the public
in having a circuit
court judge explain
the intricacies of
a judicial opinion,
which really only law school
graduates can comprehend.
A lot of times I made
decisions on the bench
that the law forced me to make,
that I sent people
to jail for crimes
that in my opinion
were victimless
and shouldn't have been crimes
and they should not
have gone to jail.
Like the three strikes on
possession of marijuana,
he went away for 20 years.
That's so absurd,
especially today where
it's legal in 37 states.
But there are times when
judges must do things
that they don't want to do
because they've taken an oath
to uphold the law and
the law requires it.
Explaining that so that the
public can understand it
is a very difficult task.
- What about if the
judge was truly radical
and I honestly don't
know enough about her,
her full resume and obviously
we're gonna hear it,
but what if they were someone
that really did not hold
any of the principles that
you mentioned at the beginning
about our founding documents
and individual rights
and they really were
activist in terms of
they wanted to
fundamentally change
the way that the country is run.
You'd want some exploratory
version of it, right?
- Well the answer is yes.
However, with Judge
Jackson, I mean,
she was confirmed to the
United States District Court
eight years ago and
then was confirmed
by this very same senate to
the Circuit Court of Appeals
one year ago.
So they've already
gone through all this.
However, if some
nominee did not believe
that the constitution was
the supreme law of the land
or believed that the
Declaration of Independence
was just Jefferson's musings
or that the first amendment
really doesn't guarantee
the freedom of speech,
that person would
probably be disqualified
and those views
should be exposed.
- All right so let's
move on to Russia
because you've
taken the position
that I fully respect
because it's hard to get
any sort of sense out
of what's going on
with Russia and Ukraine,
that sanctions actually
violate the constitution.
So can you explain that a bit?
- Sure.
And this is not anti-Joe Biden.
I honestly believe he's
doing everything he can
short of war to resist Putin.
I also believe the Putin's
ultimately going to win
and that by our
arming the Ukrainians
we're probably making it worse,
bloodier and more deadly.
However, the sanctions
fall into three categories,
seizing assets, freezing assets,
and interfering with contracts.
So under the fourth amendment,
if the government
freezes a bank account,
they freeze your bank
account for example,
and you can't take any
money out, that's a seizure.
And under the fourth amendment,
the government can
only seize something
with a search warrant
after they demonstrate
to a judge like I was,
I signed hundreds of these,
probable cause of crime.
So if they seize your
yacht in the Bay of Naples,
if the Carabinieri which
is the Italian version
of the FBI seizes your
yacht in the Bay of Naples
and they won't let you on it.
And they've sent it to Port
Newark so that the feds
can actually own it and sell it.
They have seized your
property illegally.
If they've frozen
your bank account
without a search warrant,
they have frozen your
bank account illegally.
If they have interfered with
lawful commercial transactions,
if, for example, you're an
importer of Stolichnaya vodka,
and you've paid for a cargo
ship full of Stolichnaya,
and it arrives at Port
Newark or Chicago or Detroit,
and the feds send it away,
well then the feds
have interfered
with your lawful
commercial transactions.
The fifth amendment says if
the government wants life,
liberty, contractual rights
or property income
from the contract,
they have to have a jury trial
at which fault is proven.
Now under what basis
is President Biden
engaging these sanctions?
There's two statutes, Dave,
that the feds enacted.
One is the International
Economic Emergency Act of 1977,
Carter era.
One is the Magnitsky
Act of 2016, Obama era.
Both of these statutes
allow the president
without any evidence or
judicial process whatsoever
to declare a human
being or an entity,
foreign human being,
or foreign entity,
a violator of human rights
and seize their assets.
And if they want
the assets back,
if you're this billionaire
whose yacht was stolen
by the Carabinieri
and you want it back,
you have to come to America,
submit to the federal
court jurisdiction,
which they're never gonna do,
because they're afraid
they'll get arrested
for some trumped up charge.
And then you have to
prove that you are not
a human rights violator.
How do you prove a negative?
And that's "Alice
in Wonderland."
You're in a federal court.
The government
wants your property,
and you have to prove
that you're not what
they say you are?
Forget about it.
The government has
the burden of proof.
The person whose life,
liberty, or property
the government wants
always is presumed innocent
and to presume to be the
valid owner of the life,
liberty, or property.
So these two statutes,
which have not been
challenged constitutionally,
because these foreigners
are not gonna come here
to challenge them,
give the president
dictatorial powers,
which he has exercised.
- Why do you think
some of our companies,
maybe that do
business with Russia
say I'll use the
example that you gave.
I mean, you're just
an American company
who's a vodka importer.
Who's now your business in
essence has been destroyed.
I mean should they be suing
the federal government
at this point?
- Yes they should.
- Yeah.
- Yes they they should,
look, the government,
I don't know what you
think of this phrase,
The government loves to hate.
- I like it.
- Okay so for 200 years-
- Mostly a libertarian yeah.
- The federal government
hated black people,
either as slaves
or under Jim Crow,
the federal government told
us to hate the Soviet Union
and then hate Iran,
and then hate Iraq,
and then hate Saddam Hussein.
And then pardon
this, hate COVID.
Now it's hate Putin and
hate all things Russian.
Well the Russian people have
nothing to do with this.
They have the misfortune of
being governed by a dictator.
I don't think he's crazy.
I think he's perfectly rational,
but he doesn't care about human
liberty or about human life.
And innocent people
are being punished,
are being harmed.
The ruble buys about 5% today
of what it bought a month ago.
So you're paying $15
for a loaf of bread
that should have cost $1.50.
- Yeah absolutely incredible.
I hope some of these
companies fight that.
I mean 'cause that's
where people forget.
We're now punishing Americans.
- Correct.
- These are Americans who
just happen to do business
with something that perhaps
originated in Russia.
Let's move to COVID
'cause you've hit it
a couple times here.
I mean I'm pretty
sure that anything
you're gonna say on the COVID
front, I agree with you.
I think our civil liberties
have been destroyed.
As you know, I fled California
just in the last couple months.
I now live in the
free state of Florida
because I could not
deal with the lockdowns
and the mask mandates and the
general state of depression
that it brought and all
of the closed businesses
and the dreams
that were shattered
and the whole freaking thing.
However we've still
got masks on planes,
they've still got masks on
three year olds and toddlers,
yet Joe Biden can give
the State of the Union
with a bunch of 80
year olds in a room
with no windows and that's okay.
What do you make of the
entire freaking thing?
Was this just a disaster from-
we're basically at the
two year anniversary.
Two years ago.
Should we have been
all screaming louder
and known what was coming?
- Okay so you're
scratching at the surface
of what my biggest
complaint and fear is.
I am not surprised
that the government
exercised the
dictatorial powers.
Because the government doesn't
care about human liberty.
It just cares about power
and staying in power.
And if the government
can give the impression
that it's doing something,
it will stay in power.
What has crushed me
and broken my heart
is how Americans accepted this,
how we laid down and allowed
them to close churches,
to close schools.
Well, the government
owns the schools,
but to interfere with
freedom of travel,
with freedom of assembly,
even with freedom of speech,
I mean not far
from where I am now
in this beautiful countrified
area on Palm Sunday.
Two Palm Sundays ago,
a Catholic priest was
distributing palms
wrapped in cellophane outdoors
to people in their cars
and the state
police broke it up.
The cars were too
close to each other
and they were too
close to this priest
as he physically
handed them the palms
wrapped in cellophane.
And I went berserk on air
and in my writings because
the governor who ordered this
appeared in a black
lives matter rally
and I,
the part of the
black lives matter
that I think is
absolutely legitimate.
There were 3,000 people
there that weren't masked
and he was the featured speaker.
So this is an example of
the government using power
to promote its own power
and the American
public accepted it.
I once had an argument
with Roger Ailes
about whether a dictator
could ever take over
in the United States.
And he took the
position it wouldn't.
That the public would
never stand for it.
Well, when the public is afraid,
the government's
weapon was fear.
We became a nation of
sheep and we still are
because Governor
Murphy of New Jersey,
Governor Whitmer of Michigan,
former Governor
Cuomo of New York,
that mentality could
come back in a week
if some unnamed variant
of COVID kicks in again.
- People just don't learn, huh?
- No they don't learn.
- I'm completely
with you on that.
They will bring it back
and people will do
the exact same thing.
And they will say,
thank you, sir,
may I have another?
- Yes and they value
safety and, Dave,
the illusion of safety
more than they value
personal liberty.
And that's why they
went along with it.
I have very, very many
intelligent friends
who just couldn't wait
to put that mask on.
- What do you make of the
way we began to worship,
well not we,
but many people in the
country began to worship
these agencies say
the CDC or the NIH.
These are unelected people.
They are some of them
are appointed people,
but they're unelected people
who we basically outsourced
our public policy to in terms of
who you could stand next to
and what restaurant could
be open and everything else.
And also that nobody gets fired.
I mean that if I was to take
away one thing from this,
that how has nobody
at the CDC been fired,
nobody, two weeks to
flatten the curve,
it's two years later,
nobody was fired anywhere.
- Dave nobody-
- Electing people for policy.
They get installed and
then they just exist.
- Nobody was fired in the
intelligence community
after 9/11,
people don't get fired no
matter what the calamity is
in part because the government
has enacted statutes
that insulate itself
from liability
when it drops the ball
and people get hurt.
One of my least
favorite presidents,
I'm a graduate of
Princeton University,
he was the president
of Princeton
and then the governor
of New Jersey
and then President
of the United States,
Woodrow Wilson.
Princeton has since stripped
his name from everything there.
When I was there, half
the place was named
Wilson this and Wilson that.
Created the
administrative state.
This constitutional
law professor said
we should be governed by
people smarter than we are.
Now he might not have
envisioned the CDC,
but he's the one that
started the ball rolling.
Now there are 30 or 40 of
these three and four letter
acronym government entities,
the membership on
which doesn't change,
no matter who's in the
White House or who,
what party controls Congress.
They have more
control over our lives
than the Congress does.
The only person,
the only president
in the modern era
that thumbed his nose
at this whole thing
and tried to suppress
it was Donald Trump.
And parts of it,
the intelligence and law
enforcement community
went right back at him and
we all know what happened.
- What should we do?
I mean, is there
any legal recourse?
That I've been trying to
discuss this on my show
the last couple weeks that,
as we're somewhat out
of the fog of COVID,
although I do believe somehow
magically it will reappear,
that we can't forget
all of the people
that put us in this position.
Now we're not on
the side of gulags
and jailing people
and all of that.
But do you think
there is any recourse
for public officials
who demanded
clearly unconstitutional
mandates
related to vaccines that
now they're pulling back
because they finally
realized it wasn't working.
I mean is there anything
within the legal system,
not to blow up the legal
system to jail them,
but is there anything legally
that we could be doing
so that some of these people,
that there's some repercussion,
otherwise we will
do it all again.
- The short and and
regrettable answer is no.
For the reason that we talked
about a few minutes ago,
the government has
insulated itself
from the consequences
of its own misbehavior.
Could I sue Phil Murphy,
the governor of New Jersey
because he closed the
Catholic churches,
all churches in New Jersey.
And I wasn't able to receive
the blessed sacrament on Easter.
No, I cannot.
So the answer is either
political or radical.
- You couldn't sue for violation
of the fourth amendment?
I mean, violation of, you
know, right to assembly?
I mean, is there?
- You know the
constitution has a clause
that requires standing
and standing means
that you have an injury
distinct from all others.
So if the injury
afflicts everybody,
the remedy is political.
The courts are
not gonna hear it.
If he denied just
Dave Rubin's right
to go to a restaurant or
just Judge Napolitano's right
to go to Our Lady Queen
of Peace on Easter Sunday,
you'd have the right to sue
and I'd have the right to sue.
But because Gavin Newsom denied,
I think you were in
California at the time,
everybody's right.
And because Phil Murphy
denied everybody's right,
the courts will say,
the remedy is political.
You don't like him,
throw him out of office.
So the remedy is either
political or radical.
The radical remedy is to
do how the country began.
Succeed.
We succeeded from Great Britain.
I wouldn't be surprised,
maybe not in my lifetime,
but perhaps yours.
If the federal government
can't pay its bills,
it's money becomes worthless,
and the country breaks apart
into a dozen smaller countries.
Where you are will be
the land of the free,
where Texas is will be
where I am in the Northeast,
it'll be the people's republic.
- Wow, Judge.
I did not know you
were gonna go there,
but this is a theory
I've been teasing out
a little bit on my show.
I'm kind of there,
there's a bunch of writers
talking about this.
I'm not, I don't like
the idea of succession.
And I like the idea
of the United States,
but to me, the federal
government is so outta control
for all the reasons
you've just described.
I don't think it
can be repaired.
I can tell you, and I think
I've been in California,
my guys at the counter
91 days right now
I've been in Florida.
And since I left,
I feel like I live in
a different country.
And the problem is that
in the free states,
they're not gonna want anything.
Nobody in Florida wants anything
from the people in California.
But the people in
California want something
from the people in Florida,
that's an untenable position.
- You know, the government,
the federal government
fears two things.
It fears loss of power over
certain geographical areas.
So if Florida succeeds,
feds couldn't control
Florida at all.
And it fears loss
of tax dollars.
If everybody who
lives in Florida
didn't have to pay a
federal income tax,
the feds would be
pulling their hair out
because of the same thing
would happen in Texas
and Montana and other states.
And this behemoth
that we've allowed
to grow from Woodrow
Wilson to Joe Biden
and Republicans are just
as bad, just as bad.
You know, George Bush
borrowed 3 trillion,
Donald Trump
borrowed 2 trillion,
Joe Biden borrowed 1
trillion in just one year.
That we've allowed
this monstrosity to
get out of control,
to mortgage the future
to sap our liberties,
the only way around it would
be to let it go by the wayside.
- Well then I have to ask you,
what keeps you in the northeast?
What's keeping you in
Jersey with the high taxes
and everything else?
I mean this is where the
rubber meets the road, right?
- I love my farm, I
love this property.
I love the real estate.
You are not the only friend
that asks me that
almost all of them do,
but you are one of the
happiest people I know.
- I'm telling you man
that I'm a lot happier now
than I was two months ago.
- You know, Fox sent me
to California for a year
to do a reality show.
I played myself.
It was called
"Power of Attorney."
It was a "Judge Judy" like show.
We had celebrity lawyers.
So the OJ case had just ended.
We had all the lawyers from OJ,
the late great F. Lee Bailey
and I became great friends
from this show.
There were half hour
shows, superstar lawyers.
The typical case was the
dry cleaner ruined my dress,
but he also tried to
pick up my sister.
It was nonsense like that.
I hated it.
I hated all that
time in California.
I couldn't wait to come home.
- And that's while
it was still open.
I mean, geez, okay.
I wanna cover one
more big one for you,
which I'm covering pretty
much every day here.
And it frames almost
everything I do,
which is some of
the big tech stuff
and where the law
should be involved
and where it should not,
and how that relates
to free speech.
Do you view these platforms,
Facebook, Twitter,
et cetera, as sort of
the new public square.
And if they squelch
a person or a story,
obviously in the last week,
we now know that the Hunter
Biden laptop story is legit.
And yet Facebook and Twitter,
not only banned the
story from being posted,
but literally down the New
York Post's Twitter account.
Are there some
legal remedies here
or is this just left to
congressional hearings
that nothing ever
happened for the reasons
that you've been laying
out this whole time?
- In my opinion, it should
be left to the free market.
Facebook in my view
is just a glorified
high tech bulletin board.
They own the bulletin board
and if they don't like
something that was posted,
they can take it down.
I don't like it.
I've been criticized by them,
but they are a private entity.
The last thing in
the world we want
is the federal government
involved in speech
because the government
will favor the speech
of its benefactors.
And it will favor
the speech it likes
and disfavor the speech
that is critical of it.
The free market in ideas,
as well as the free market in
electronic bulletin boards,
if you'll pardon that phrase,
is what should resolve this.
So someone like Charles Koch
should start his own Facebook
and you'll watch Mark
Zuckerberg's profits
go way down as hundreds
of millions of people
migrate over to
another bulletin board.
- Hint, hint, I suppose
at Charles Koch.
- Hint, hint.
I know him well,
and he's turned down this idea,
but I keep pushing it.
- Judge, I've
thoroughly enjoyed this.
I hope you'll come back and
good luck in Jersey man.
Listen if the
country does split,
I've got a guest room.
- You're very kind.
It's a pleasure
to be on with you,
I've admired your work for years
and I'd love to do it again.
Thank you, Dave.
Maybe you'll come on
"Judging Freedom" with me.
- I think I'm coming
on in a couple weeks.
That's what they're telling me.
- I think so.
- Great.
If you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful
conversation about law
instead of the nonstop yelling
you get everywhere else,
check out our law playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.